落ちそう
あぁやべぇ
超揺れて＞＞
ああああああぁぁぁぁぁああぁぁぁあ
これどっっぢどどっぢぢぢぢ
道がわかんねぇみちがわかんねぇ
寝っむ
うわぁ
はい、おはようございます
がちで寝起きのはじめしゃちょうです
はい、というわけで今日は
ですね
１月の６日？７日？
なんもわからん。。。。。。
今年酉年なんですけどね
ぼく、年男なんですけども
年男かつ実は厄年orz...
本厄ですね
よだれ出た！！！！！！
厄年は本来お祓いとかに行かなければならないのですが
時間がないので
正月終わり際というか、人が少なそうなタイミングを狙って
ひとりで今からお参りに行ってきます
う～わまたこうやって（カメラが）下がってくでしょ。
（あくびを伴いながら）まじ眠い＞
寝不足ってわけじゃないけど眠い
まずサークルKで飯を買いましょう
うわ～緊張してきたな
そとで撮るの苦手なんですよ、こう見えても
まって、お金（１０万円）おろそ
音楽
人がいるな～～～～～
やばい
やばいの連呼
はい、というわけで
登っていきます
鳥居
はあははぁはあ
激しく息が切れる
死亡。
復活。
中に入りました
この奥にたぶんお参りするところがあります
この奥におみくじがある気がします
というわけで
おみくじ無事ゲットしました
僕の今年の運勢は・・・・・
ここにかかっています（書かれています）
行ける気もするんですよね
さぁ開けてい見ます
たのむ、大凶とかはやめてほしい
おおおおおおおおおおおおおお
忠吉
中吉
しばらく音読
なんかあったらすぐ買いますね
悪くはないんじゃないですか？
中吉はいい方だった気がするので
去年は１年お菓子を食べないという
割と我慢チックなことしてたんですけど・・・・・・
今年は一変して、やりたいことはたくさんあったんですけど
一つ決めたので、それだけ発表したいと思います
やべぇ人多いな
この中で言うのか（早く消えろ）
今年の目標行きます
今年は
遊戯王のルールを全部覚える
ああやべぇ、めっちゃみられてるめっちゃみられてるめっちゃみられてる！